what's up believe in 1887 I am making my
next to 54 series and I want your
feedback on input on what to do next for
those of you who don't know what the to
54 series is the idea is that for every
day for 254 days I send you a mourning
video for free to help you build
confidence in a certain topic the reason
why it's 254 is because it takes up to
two hundred and fifty four days to build
a habit
the average is 66 days and minimum is
eighteen days and it takes a maximum of
two hundred and fifty four days so the
idea here is I will be with you for
every step of the way even if you are
the slowest learning human alive I am
still with you you have no excuses for
not building that skill
so the first 254 that I made was around
confidence it's getting amazing results
people are writing in every day saying
they're gaining more confidence just by
watching the videos it's amazing because
it's it's confidence being injected into
your daily environment you are a
reaction of your environment you are a
product of your environment so the more
you inject something into your
environment the more you will become
like that and so by getting a little hit
of confidence every day people are
becoming more confident we've got
thousands of people who signed up for it
and again it's free and it's 30 seconds
to a couple minutes every single morning
if you haven't signed up for you can go
it's free but I'm looking to do two more
and I want your feedback so from the
beginning I wanted to have three
different kinds of 250 fours I wanted to
have one around topics like
self-confidence like self love like
believe like dealing with haters those
kind of topical issues to is your own
demographics since people tend to learn
best at the beginning from people who
look like them so wanted to have a
series around black entrepreneurs around
women entrepreneurs Latino entrepreneurs
and down the line basically be able to
learn everyday from someone who looks
like you and then the third one along
the same vein is around industries
people like to learn from people who are
doing the same thing that they are so we
have a series for writers we have a
series for actors we have a series for
computer programmers like whatever it is
that you do that industry this series is
designed for you for two hundred fifty
four days to get morning inspiration to
give you the motivation as well as
tactical things and what you should be
doing so the first one is done is
confidence the theme
the first theme is confidence that's
already done is having great success the
second one around demo I'm gonna do the
black excellent series I had it on my
channel for a while I had black
Excellence for black entrepreneurs we
had girlboss and we had somos which is
for Latino community and the amount of
hate that we got on the 'black excellent
series was actually staggering believe
nation is a pretty positive place and in
the girlboss series in the somos series
were accepted pretty well there's always
the outlier haters but the amount of
negativity that I got on the 'black
excellent series of any series I've ever
done on my channel was the worst and so
really in my mind just speaks to the
amount of racism that still exists and
so I think we need to have the black
excellence to 54 that's gonna be the
first one that I do target in a
demographic where I need your help with
is the industry what is the first
industry that we should tackle should it
be right or should it be active should
be programmers should it be stock
traders like what should it be I want to
know I want your feedback if you could
pick one industry you're probably gonna
pick your own which is amazing but if
you had to pick one industry for the
2:54 what would it be please please
please please let me know leave it down
the comments below I'm gonna be paying
attention future to 54s are gonna be
decided through your dollars so every
time you buy a t-shirt a book a workshop
past that I'm putting on I donate I
match so whatever the retail cost of
this t-shirt is I put towards a 254 of
your choosing so if you spend you know
15 bucks on a book you send in the
receipt then we applied that 15 bucks
towards whatever 254 that you want to
create but that's future 254 s I want to
figure out the first three I want to
have a demo a sample in each of the
three categories again the topic around
confidence a demo black excellence and
an industry which is what I want to
figure out now I want to have the three
samples ready to go so that it gives
people a sense of what future 254 could
be created because my goal with this is
I want to have hundreds I'm not stopping
at three I want to have hundreds of
these which will mean hundreds of
thousands of videos that we're gonna put
up on a channel all unlisted being sent
out specifically for you to help you
build the motivation the mindset the
habits that you need to become
successful and achieve your dreams so it
starts with you I need
your feedback and your energy if you
haven't already done it please let me
know what injury should we start with
put it in the comments below and of
course if you want to build your
confidence check out the 250 for
confidence series the link is in the
description below or you might enjoy the
video right next to me on how to
jumpstart your confidence continue to
believe and I'll see you there and so
learning how to empower yourself part of
doing that is standing up to yourself
you got to stand up inside yourself
sometimes and say shut up